[Music]
welcome to the meeting of northeast
alberta district council's cabinet
i'm alex dale i'm the leader of the
district council and i'm joined by
several uh cabinet colleagues
as well as several officers as well in
the chamber and we have council mark
foster
joining us by the zoo
before we start with the meeting i think
i'd just like to say i think we're all
aware
of the news around the poor health of
the queen emergency the queen
and obviously we wish to express on
behalf of the council our
our thoughts and prayers are very much
would
um the first item is apologies for
absence have we received them
i haven't received anything
um
next item is declaration of interest
already
okay
a minute to the last meeting uh held on
the 4th of august are we all happy to
confirm there's a triangular record
i'll move them second picture thanks for
okay that's watching
and then the first item is the out of
hours scrutiny review now we don't have
uh councillor tate in attendance at the
moment he's the chair of the community
scrutiny committee
but my colleague councillor cutepit
and they've considered similar services
elsewhere such as rolls over
um
and policies and already sort of allow
for ourselves work uh by existing
officers where needed during this
environment
sort of late night visits to
drink establishments etc so i think what
these regional community are
recommending
is that we sort of look at that in more
detail and that we also publicize that
more because i think one of the things
that came out of
so that's the
main recommendation they're making is to
have that key contact police and so i'm
i'm happy to
move to accept those reputations and
make them for one thing i'd like to add
this sort of portfolio
just to have a look at whether that
new dedicated page is working and
whether
you have a chat about this we are fun
that's really the best way
um
are there any more comments
and then the next one
is the ict and transformation screening
[Music]
digging into what we do
um
much appreciated professionalism was
good
on the recommendations uh the set of
recommendations
on the first one
actually operate sort of um know a
hybrid model at the moment some things
are for those related to department
phones others are done centrally
and so it's a bit of a blend there
possibly some things being more
centralized will be helpful
a lot of that will interact with the
second recommendation which is moving
forward 365 which is a project that's
been underway
for a couple of years or more now i
think
it's a massively complex thing to
achieve cancer systems
microsoft 365.
[Music]
it's something that we're in the middle
of doing already people actually
live now
[Music]
the single sign-on system again
internationally in switzerland 365 it's
kind of building what they've been built
from
simplifying sign-on
for our residents in particular
something that um
we will consider how we can advance that
further
and uh the only the only one looking at
concern is the fourth recommendation
which is the use of the council chamber
for um
um assistant's advice for envisioning
training and so on
um well we will definitely consider it
but i would say that with the things
that could be happening and the capital
trading is possibly increasing for
might not work that well but we'll
consider all the recommendations so
happy to uh
to propose the
recommendations of the report
okay that's okay you know
are there any other
thank you very much
and then the next item is the risk
management strategy for 202.
um you don't have cancer
our most
what we do is is right
uh there are some amendments however and
i'll just briefly tell what they are
there in section we've spent quite a bit
of time
uh detailing uh the change in our
environment and our risk environment we
feel that's important for the reader
uh certainly
external readers and and understanding
that we've gotta think about the
voicemail knowledge about changing
environment and as a result changing the
change
the second change of note is around risk
appetite which factor is an area that
unless you're immersed in it it's a
difficult one to get your head around so
spend a little bit more time explaining
how
brisket is assessed and how
there's not one single measure for the
council it's split into a variety of
different strands depending upon
the
subject in question
uh that we've added a uh apprentices in
there that helps explain how we
reach our risk management habitat and
then the final fundamental change i
guess is the action back
that's been updated to reflect our
continuing improvement requirements that
we've identified
uh and as the report said this is not to
be confused registers fish registers
are kept
used daily by officers uh then track
specific risks so the action plans about
setting out where we go within future
just one final addition that's not in
this version that we
[Music]
and that's the role we play with in the
lrf
uh a community was registered covers
items that are risks to
an area the emergency rates right
through the pandemic design which we
know about recent experiences
uh the members to
accept all of you
thanks lee yeah i'm happy to uh
[Music]
and then the next item
is the funding to voluntary and
community organizations
all the opportunities with the support
that we do give to the long-term
organizations
this is
[Music]
as i say to make sure that um
and
there are still
a raft of problems
i suppose for people
which become even more acute in the next
few months it's benefits that housing
and employment
and so we make sure that we target on
grants to make
to make certain that
it's reaching the right people i think
it's interesting to note that over the
period under review
more than 19 000 households
and i think that's the best
and we have made sure that um
the monitoring process has
shown that
the organizations we have support have
been supported worked extremely well
extremely hard
and
you know along the way they continued
to
to the district as a whole as well as
council and for residents in particular
so i'm happy to just recommend that we
know the report
um the work will come when we look
forward to the next set
and the challenges that they will bring
into your current situation
thank you
thank you very much
for watching
[Music]
very different circumstances going
forward
and we had a
really good response to
it and
i just wondered whether we can
be here to replicate that
over the next few months as uh know
announcements today in terms of the
energy capacity
that's a lot of comfort to
some people but not everybody
and the government made this seven
million pounds available and that weighs
about 1200 pounds
to
people's certain benefits
so it's just about making sure that if
we get
satisfied with disability benefits
that's a significant
across the district there are
various parts of the child funding that
most people don't know about so can we
do it for our mark team for the
comprehensive listing
um
some of these and challenges some of the
people supporting making sure that
offices at the moment
and criticals
around various levels of support um in
terms of the customer crisis and one of
those as you like to say was just about
getting information out to residents
financial support that's out there
to help them as well as practical advice
around um you know keeping costs down as
much as they possibly can so
i know there'll be some that'll be some
announcements
over the course of probably the next
week
where we'll be detailing exactly how
we're
um
[Music]
okay so on that basis
and there are no
other
items
[Music]
you